brian
are you an avenger
i'm not an avenger
nina
legally you're not allowed to ask me
that
does hawkeye suck
that's the question we've got on the
daca today i'm here with tom and nina
they are going to argue their positions
i'm going to be the judge of whether or
not hawkeye
in fact
sucks
on the pro hawkeye sucks side we have
nina starner
on the con
hawkeye
does not suck side we've got tom
meisfeerd so
we're gonna do a little uh high school
debate style thing that i vaguely
remember from when i was in high school
about ten thousand years ago
we're gonna start with opening
statements from nina and then tom and
then each person is gonna have the
opportunity to offer a rebuttal and then
i will weigh in and decide whether or
not
hawkeye sucks nina does hawkeye suck
yeah
um extremely hard actually
there you go that's my whole argument
good night yeah
that's it that's all i've got uh hawkeye
sucks so here's why hawkeye sucks here's
why i have never given a flying fart
about hawkeye um so he shows up in
avengers and immediately gets possessed
by the tesseract so you have no idea who
he is for like most of the movie you're
just like oh so he's bad maybe um
because he's obviously like fighting
against the avengers
but and then he like they unpossess him
or whatever and he's friends with
natasha and the
and for the remainder of the movies he
does exactly one interesting thing which
is be married to linda cardellini uh
congratulations to that man but other
than that he does absolutely nothing of
value he has easily the worst weapon and
like
his connection to black widow is
something that i'll keep touching on but
like i i'm always annoyed that like
everyone has like thor has a hammer and
iron man has a suit and cap has a shield
and they're just like give her a gun
like a like in that famous like avengers
shot in the circle like she's just
reloading like a tiny shotgun and
that sucks like she should have a better
weapon than that but his is just a bow
and arrow like he should be like which
is worse than a gun which is worse than
a gun because it's slower
and arrows
i would imagine take a very long time to
make so where are you getting all of
these and like if you run out it's not
like you can be like oh like i have
another arrow clip like i feel like you
have a finite amount of arrows it's fine
for katniss everdeen but it's not fine
for an avenger like she lived in the
woods he's in new york city um
he
continues to do absolutely nothing
interesting for several films to the
point where i literally can't remember
which movie he's he's even in until we
get to like infinity war and end game
and after his family vanishes at the
beginning of end game he gets the
world's stupidest haircut and goes on a
vaguely problematic mission to hunt
people in asia for reasons i don't fully
understand
and then when he gets brought
up
you wait your turn away
yeah i will wrap this up in one second
and the only reason that he gets to live
instead of a much more interesting
character who i will probably argue
again gets shafted by the entire
cinematic universe by getting killed off
before her standalone movie even shows
up the only reason that he lives and she
doesn't is because he is worthy of being
alive because he has a wife and children
and she doesn't have a family so
uh that sucks extremely hard he should
have been like no i'm gonna kill myself
my kids will be fine i mean like
no disrespect to his kids but like
that's him having a family does not make
him like more worthy of life so hawkeye
sucks
all right thank you
very good tom your opening statement on
whether or not hawkeye sucks tom does
hawkeye suck
brian
[Music]
consider hawkeye for a moment
it's true he has no powers it's true
he has a costume so dumb that even the
mcu won't try to grunge it up
and yes it's true that he's probably the
kind of guy who would give cabela's gift
cards a christmas but
[Music]
oh my god that's so good
does he suck
let's consider his accomplishments he is
an expert marksman
married to linda cardellini as
my associate
brought up
he's an adoring father
and
with quicksilver and black widow under
his belt he's killed two times as many
avengers as the next leading super
villain
[Laughter]
these are not small things consider
nina's argument
that he has a stupid haircut i put it to
you that he has an awesome haircut and
end game
and he carries a sword with him to work
and he's in his 40s how does that not
describe the coolest guy you've ever met
in your life
and i put it to you brian and nina
that a man is more than just the sum of
us parts
we have to consider where this man came
from hawkeye in the comics do you know
where he comes from
ohio
yeah it comes from the circus
oh waverly iowa
well i wasn't far off the small town of
waverly
iowa the hawkeye state a little on the
nose yes i'll give you that but
yeah that's true
waverly iowa i hate that
town motto
when you're here
you're 289.9 miles from chicago waverly
iowa
the home
of character actor michael talbot from
miami vice and that's it iowa the state
home to captain kirk the itchiest star
trek captain miss piggy and according to
wikipedia
others
[Laughter]
and what did he manage to do he picked
himself up by his bootstraps and he got
out there
he made something of himself he became
an avenger
brian
are you an avenger
i'm not an avenger
nina
legally you're not allowed to ask me
that
that's the end of tom's statement
nina a rebuttal
rebuttal uh yeah if a guy i knew in his
40s carried his sword to work i'd call
the cops because i'd be like
he's definitely he has a manifesto
somewhere on his computer about you know
people who have wronged him and i don't
feel good about the situation yeah i
mean okay yeah he's killed two avengers
i don't even know what
um i genuinely don't even know where to
begin um
yeah i don't knowing nothing about his
comics origin even if i knew what his
comics origin was i would still be like
oh like you could replace most of jeremy
renner in these movies with like a
cardboard cut out of hawkeye giving a
thumbs up and i would not notice like
his first appearance his first
appearance he was in a a circus sideshow
oh boy and i'm doing what he's a regular
man did he just shoot things he's
shooting arrows really good he's great
at shooting air and then iron man shows
up and he's like oh shucks everyone's
really interested in that iron man i
better dress up like uh uh in purple and
then commit crimes what is iron man
better than iron man doing at a circus
in iowa i don't think he was in ireland
of life's beautiful tapestry i think the
circus was in new york at the time i'll
give him i'll give iron man that no he
wasn't at a circus in iowa but i was
like that doesn't track at all for like
tony stark's whole deal but you know if
you're a
a more casual marvel fan like i am
without the lore of the comics behind
you you don't know any of that you just
look at jeremy renner and you think
about his album and his app and you're
just like
no
are you saying that you would have been
more on board if we'd included the
circus situation in his
screen portrayal
if there had been just 40 minutes
maybe that's what we'll see maybe no i
just thought of that too i was like what
if that's in hawkeye i will
i will i will leave the earth
i will not continue
okay so i think yeah is that the end of
your rebuttal i guess
my rebuttal is just
nothing used to convince me i still hate
him and i
i'm so mad that florence pugh is going
to be wasted on the hawkeye series
trying to kill him because also like
that fight should not be a fight she
should immediately be able to murder a
guy with a bow and arrow
like she's explosion proof
yeah we did find that out yeah
and she killed her she killed a guy by
putting him in a bear costume and
setting him on fire in a different movie
so she's capable of anything
that's what happened to ursa major in
the mcu that's right
tom
uh rebuttal to nina
i mean i feel like you did that kind of
in your opening statement where you
took her to task about the haircut no i
don't know anything stupid talk some
more there's plenty of other stuff that
we can talk about with hawkeye he's a
phenomenal character with plenty of
depth and nion 60 years of backstory to
consider nina starner he's a remarkable
guy who's been brought up in multiple
different iterations we don't just have
to talk about the mcu version of hawkeye
we could talk about the ultimate comics
version of hawkeye written by mark
millar the one with an eminem haircut
and the sick hoop earrings and the gross
story where he pulls out his own emails
and he throws them at people they kill
i'm way more stuck on the hoop earring
than i am the fingernail thing two hoop
earrings and some wrap around sunglasses
everybody in this house with uh cutler
with a silverware from his uh
from a silverware drawer he's a
remarkable character we could talk about
uh the the version from the matt
fraction comic that won multiple eisner
awards and told everybody that wow this
guy actually has something to do and
introduced lucky the pizza dog that's a
heck of a guy too but i think that my
favorite thing about hawkeye
and i had a lot of time to think about
that is that you know we we were gonna
do
this episode like three weeks ago and
then we had to keep putting it off um
my favorite thing about hawkeye is that
if hawkeye was ever like hey do you guys
want to talk about hawkeye
he wouldn't make somebody wait three
weeks to do it and maybe give them the
opportunity to put together an entire
visual aid okay that then uh has it been
on your wall for a month
oh no like the eye of sauron staring
down a person's anxieties for her
so wouldn't you say tom that uh knowing
more about hawkeye has recently made
your life worse
yeah
i think i think we've determined
yeah
sorry jeremy i tried i'm sorry jeremy
knowing about hawkeye made tom's life
worse hawkeye sucks that guy sucks i'm
sorry damn it
it was close i wasn't sure which way it
was going to go yeah
nina nina crushed it at the end you got
it
okay
you sucks yeah you earned it
thank you
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
you